the best thing to do is to read and
listen at the same time because you
could do it a lot faster and you retain
a lot more also listening in your own
voice helps a lot and gpt3 pre-trained
models for text punctuation
classification task the distilled models
are small and fast for mobile loose cost
in pric and
better all right guys bang bang I've got
Cliff here Cliff I thought a great place
to start is the rise of audio it seems
like everywhere I turn I see Amazon's
audiobook sales exploding I see
obviously things like uh Alexa or Siri I
see um you know podcasts everything
seems to be going more and more audio
what is happening with the rise of
audio so this hey nice to meet you by
the way I'm play from the CEO spey um
here's the way to think about it humans
have been listening and speaking for
like hundreds of thousands of years
we've only been reading for like a
couple of thousand and reading is an
amazing hack that people made right you
have a couple of glyphs and you read
them and you understand what they say
say but when you read you're employing
about 70% of your brain decoding and
about 30% actually comprehending when
you listen it's like 3% is dedicated
towards comp decoding and then 97% is
comprehending um a couple of things
happen um the first one is you have to
remember that text is very easy to store
audio is a little bit more difficult to
store and a little bit more difficult to
stream you had this huge shift that
happened when podcasts started to rise
about like 15 years ago because it was
the first time that now everybody had a
device in their pocket that was
connected to the internet where you
didn't need to store all the audio files
on your phone right if you remember you
know the big thing with the iPhone came
out to Steve Jobs was like 1,000 songs
in your pocket 1,000 songs is like two
podcast episodes so you couldn't store
them on the device so one you solved the
solution where you didn't need to store
all of it because you could stream it
and you know download upload speeds
became fast enough and then everybody
got used to having earphones in their
pocket that were really mobile and then
you got airpods and airpods really
really change the game because now
you're not getting your you know
earphones stuck in the door handle um
people carry them every single day along
with your wallet along with your keys
you have your airpods with you and in
addition you had a couple more changes
number one is YouTube released double
speed for YouTube so a lot of people
listen to things at Double speed right
I'm sure the majority of people
listening to this are listening at 1.5x
speed so you had rise of podcasts rise
of audiobooks double speed WhatsApp
messages and audio messages double speed
YouTube videos and audiobooks absolutely
exploded and so at speechify there's
about 25 million people who use
speechify the average American reads it
about 180 words per minute um but it
used to be that most people who would
come to speechify would set the speed at
210 words per minute which is about like
1.15 X speed we've noticed that over the
last like two three years the average
person comes in and sets to 2.4 sorry
240 words per minute so like closer to
1.5 1.4 speed and then they build up in
the first like four months of using
speechify to listening at like 350 to
400 words per minute um my experience is
I moved to the US when I was 13 from
Israel and I didn't speak English and so
I learned English by listening to Harry
Potter audiobooks 22 times in a row and
in the beginning I would listen at like
0.75 X speed because I I was just
getting used to the language but with
time I started to listen at 1X and then
1.25 and then 1.5 and 2x and 2.5 and 3X
and then I built spee ofy and made it
easier for me so now I listen to most
things at like 700 words per minute so I
have to coach myself to speak a little
slower um but that's the first segment
is it's more accessible and people have
trained themselves to listen faster and
by the way listening fast is skill in
the same way that running fast is a
skill and once you get good at it
there's a couple of things that you
unlock number one is the ability to
listen and do other things at the same
time so in the same way that you can
walk and breathe or walk and chew gum
most people have now learned to walk and
listen to an audiobook at once or listen
to a podcast at the same time um I used
to give a lot of talks to kids in
universities and high schools and people
be like oh I listen to an audiobook but
like I didn't understand it really well
I didn't like it and I was like well
this is the first book you listen to in
an audiobook right you probably didn't
retain the first book you read well
either so you got to listen to 10 books
before you can knock whether you're an
auditory learner or not and I've never
actually met someone who listened to 10
audiobooks I didn't keep doing it more
and then we can go more into AI wherever
you want to take it yeah so one of the
things that is interesting is you can do
more things right the downside is that
you may not remember as much of it and
um you know I'm a person who for years
uh only listen to audiobooks so like I
was like the perfect customer for you
and Audible and all these guys um and I
told a story before but a friend handed
me a physical book about two years ago
and was like hey uh you should read the
book I sat down and tried to read and I
could not concentrate like i' had lost
the skill of read reading the physical
book and some of it's social media and
doom scrolling and and all this kind of
stuff and made me think more critically
about it and so now I probably do I
would say 80 to 85% physical books 15%
is uh still audio right there's certain
books that just for whatever reason I I
I enjoy them especially when the author
is reading it you know something about
the voice being uh kind of unique um but
then I noticed now there's Tik Tok
videos there's Instagram videos and the
audio that is being used here it is kind
of AI generated audio it is faster it is
being clipped in a way that holds your
attention more so what are you guys
seeing that is kind of the intersection
of many of these different Trends you
have kind of the the rise of audio you
have this AI generation that you guys
have really helped to Pioneer with
speechify and then you have it kind of
being used for entertainment purposes
that really hold people's attention and
also deliver information to them yeah so
there's like three points you touched on
so let me hit all all them the first one
was regarding uh reading versus
listening so the best thing to do is to
read and listen at the same time because
you could do it a lot faster and you
retain a lot more so what most people
who use PFI will do is the nice thing
about it is it'll highlight the words
for you while it's reading you can do it
on your computer you can do it on your
phone but like if I go here and I open a
random file um and let me text
passification whatever um and I pick
like let's do like boom hi so also
listening in your own voice helps a lot
um in terms of retention um Rober and
gpt3 pre-trained models for a text
punctuation classification task the
distilled models are small and fast for
mobile loose cost impres privac
speech so that's what most people who
use speech will do is actually
70% computer open in front of them um
and so people listen and read at the
same time and a lot of times what
students especially will do is they'll
use the scan F feature to take a picture
of their textbook and then they'll set
the phone to the side they'll follow in
the book and they listen at the same
time and they get the higher attention
you still get you know the filling of
the physical book because like there's
also a tactile thing that matters um
with regards to how we make the AI
behind how to generate these voices and
how to make them retain really well
here's how it works so AI is really just
uh statistics it's exceptional pattern
matching and so what you do is you take
a 100 million hours of speaker data
right you and me speaking you know Hugh
Jackman saying something whatever it
might be and you feed all of that audio
into an AI model as well as the text and
then you do a lot of fancy computer
science to try and make it uh super
efficient not cost too much generate
very quickly and also be exceptionally
accurate so one thing you spend a lot of
time on is this thing called the loss
function that figures out how accurate
or not accurate is the actual MP3 output
after you put in text and if you get
that really well you end up with a
system like speechify that can generate
almost anyone's voice extremely
accurately relatively instantly and it
takes us onethird of a second to
generate a second worth of
audio um and then you get to AV test so
you know people listen to more than six
billion words per month with spe giy um
and so we run a lot of tests and people
tell us this sounded good this sounded
bad this sounded good this sounded bad
and you feedback back into the model and
you see well did the person actually
retain on this book or did they not
retain on this book and if they didn't
retain on this book what do I need to
change about my audio output to make it
sound really good and then so that kind
of how we started is this b2c product
that helped people um scan physical
books upload documents read their Kindle
books you can click into Kindle and then
we were like okay well we built all
these fundamental models all around
speech to Speech Text to Speech
transcription translation natural
language processing optic correct
recognition for b2c purposes let's also
allow businesses to use this because we
found that half the traffic we got was
people looking for B2B Solutions and
half of it was people looking for b2c
Solutions and so for podcasters like
yourself you know you can hypothetically
if it was not a video component like
just give it a script and it'll read the
entire thing to you and we have a lot of
podcasters that are now signing up for
speechify to do that because it saves
them time or you can translate yourself
to spe speaking in Japanese or Chinese
or you know whatever you want and so we
added those models to a video interface
that we built on the web and you can
upload whatever text you want you can
upload whatever video you want or
podcast you want and it can let you
translate between text and voice voice
from one language to the other language
um and it just saves people a lot of
time and people have gotten used to
these types of voices and kind of that's
how another thing I think is really
interesting is uh let's say that we have
somebody who speaks English and somebody
who speaks Spanish both speak those
individual languages they do not
understand the other when you introduce
this technology now those two people can
talk to each other there's a lot of
ramifications to that and it feels
pretty important that eight billion
people can now all speak the same
language and understand each other right
um but also what you're talking about
between text and speech is another form
of translation right we're now getting
two different types of things to come
together and so is this kind of end
result that language doesn't matter you
know content type doesn't matter like at
the end of the day it's just the
information will more seamlessly
frictionlessly uh kind of move between
individuals creators audience Etc and
language audio text Etc just all of that
stuff that used to be really high
friction points kind of falls into the
background this episode is brought to
you by cal.com what do I have in common
with Chad Hurley from YouTube Toby from
Shopify and Alexis from 776 and the
co-founder of Reddit we all use cal.com
instead of cly and we are all early
investors as well cal.com is leading the
charge of scheduling Platforms in the
open-source sphere offering you the
chance to harness the efficiency
previously reserved for lead
corporations and Tech gurus if you like
to have your calendar organized and be
able to have an efficient exchange when
scheduling but you love all of the
benefits of open-source technology than
cal.com for you they are transforming
sophisticated calendar management into
an accessible tool for all via a
userfriendly interface you can customize
it and you can make your calendar work
for you use code pomp for $500 off when
you set up your team with cal.com today
again go to cal.com
cal.com and use code pomp to get $500
off when you sign up cal.com an
open-source tool that allows you to take
back control of your calendar be
efficient when scheduling and make sure
that no one can steal your time you're
actually you're asking an excellent
question and the answer is yes and no so
first of all um I think this Nelson
mandelas said um you know if you talk to
a man in a language he understands you
talk to his brain if you talk to a man
in a language that is his language you
talk to his heart it's very true um and
so that's you know another piece of
technology that we're very proud that
we're able to offer people and you're
right there's a lot of nuance that you
get to resolve when you have this
especially when you can keep the actual
vocal intonation with speech to speech
when you do the translation not just
machine translation um and so we've had
to spend a lot of time on our algorithms
making sure that the translation is not
just accurate but it also conveys with
it the semantic analysis of the tone
that's one two when you have this
translation that happens between text
and
video technically the person can
understand what the video said that
doesn't mean the person will retain on
the video it doesn't mean the person
will engage on the video and so there is
a because it's not scientific it's more
of an art let's call it you know a
genius there's a genius that some people
Mr Beast is a great example have of
being able to create a piece of content
that people want to watch they're
curious they retain and there's not a
second where they would click off we're
not at the point where the ability to
translate content from one language to
another or from one medium to the other
is so accurate that it'll keep that form
of genius and so you still will always
need people in the mix in order to make
that final judgment call that is more
like a gentic qu like what what is the
thing that makes this so attractive and
unique um but it does mean that the AI
portion can alleviate 90% of the work
talk to me about this rise of artificial
intelligence when it comes specifically
to audio um we've obviously seen the
concern around deep fakes we see the
whole like responsible AI movement um is
it a problem like should we be worried
about the fact that people can now clone
their own voice or even maybe more
concerning clone other people's voices
and make them say anything and then how
do you think about if I hear an audio
clip is it real or not like how do we
start to kind of cyh through some of the
stuff yeah so this is definitely
something that is very important um and
requires to be very responsible so this
is one thing at spei that we spend a lot
of time thinking about is AI safety um
and there's a lot of technology that we
built internally that we haven't yet
publicly released because we do it
gradually we're waiting for the world to
pick up to be ready for it um and we're
doing small a tests to make sure that
there's zero chance of abuse um there's
a couple of ways we think about it the
first one is we always put the content
owner in the driver seat for example we
have Partnerships with all of the top um
book publishers to resell their
audiobooks and their ebooks um but we
only do that with permission you can go
and listen to Snoop Dogg's Voice or Mr
BEAST's Voice or grenth potro's voice at
speechify those are things where like
there are official Partnerships with
them and then we have the ability to
clone your own voice and the way that we
do that is we say hey if you have the
device and I'm speaking a unique text
that the device shows me that changes
over time cool I can add my voice I can
even send it to my friend they can Pro
be provisioned to use it and I can have
my mom you know read out my grandmother
read out my girlfriend read whatever it
might be I can't just upload any random
person's voice and listen with it
because that is not something that is
secure or safe now sometimes I'll get a
message from the bank being like hey
voice over IP sign into your bank
account with your voice and I'm like
this is ridiculous like that like you're
asking to get hacked um and so it's
important to realize that these types of
Technologies exist now one thing that's
featured by um uh we built internally
and we're going to offer uh externally
soon is a classifier you can upload any
uh piece of audio and we can tell you
whether it was AI generated or not so
the thing to know is that um because AI
is really exceptional at pattern
recognition you can then reverse
engineer any audio file uh because it
geometrically makes sense like the the
audio pattern is different than the
audio pattern you get from a normal
person you don't get as much sound it's
less choppy it like makes geogra it
makes sense um the way to think about it
is in mathematics uh there's a concept
called a polinomial so yal a plus BX
plus C whatever um and uh you can also
think about it like images in computer
science so there's a JPEG which is a
bunch of pixels together and if you
expand it it gets pixelated but there's
a SVG which is a polinomial that
represents a shape and if you expand it
it is not pixelated the same is true for
AI generated audio and so you can by and
large always tell obviously you can't
tell with your human ear but you can
tell if you run it through a processor
and so that'll be you know a thing that
you need to do in the same way that the
New York Times if to publish a piece of
content they need to fact check it
you'll need to fact check hey is this
audio real is the this audio not and is
this something where like eventually
Apple or Android operating systems or
maybe the phone carrier somebody will be
able to like hey right now the voice on
the phone is actually AI generated and
almost like alert you um this is a good
question so these types of things often
take a very long time to roll out like
think about spam with email like you
still get spam in your email um and
Gmail is then a really good job of
fighting that but like that'll always be
a problem same thing here so uh I'm sure
that the phone carrier has a has a deep
incentive to solve this problem because
there are laws in the United States
about you know um rooc calling and uh
the more we resolve that the better for
everybody uh however I think that at the
same time you'll have a bunch of other
pieces of software that let you pull the
future forward a little bit for yourself
as a user if is a problem that you care
about right so there's a thing called
robocar that you can download and it'll
Auto automatically stop spam calls um
there's a bunch of Chrome extensions
that you can download um both by the way
for uh your desktop Chrome so speery is
a desktop Chrome extension but you can
also download the feify mobile Safari
extension that works on your iPhone um
you could for example take a screen
recording upload it to we haven't
released this yet an app that has a
classifier that tells you hey this is
real this is fake um you know I remember
many years ago there was a a Mitt Romney
um clip about him talking about the 47%
if you remember this yes tank
tanked a lot of his prospects and that
could have been completely
faked and this is something that has
always existed in politics and you know
in corporate Espionage um and it's it's
very very important to understand and
you know the last election cycle we had
so much conversations about fake news
and this upcoming election cycle is GNA
be absolutely ridiculous and the problem
is that you are speaking to you know to
everybody whether they're educated about
this technology or not and so uh it's
very very difficult to have a megaphone
to make sure that everybody is aware of
how good technology has gotten um and
that's why there's a responsibility and
an onus on companies that are able to
create this content to do it responsibly
now here's the difference um there's
this like cyberpunk portion of you know
the web sphere which is Engineers who
just love making things that push
boundaries and they're not doing it
inside of the context of a company they
might not even be based in the United
States and the way that AI Works in
general is we're very much focus on open
source like everything that we make we
like to share with other people we let
them use it we might not share the data
but we'll share the models or how we
built the models and so there's a lot of
Open Source content out there that's not
as high quality as spey it's not as easy
to use as spey but someone who's very
technical and really willing to do it
can set something up which means that
you know Bad actors can always do things
by themselves in a clandestine Manner
and uh it's I mean it's not even a
matter of time it's already here like
someone who wanted to cause harm with
this type of Technology
already has the ability to do this
through open source repositories and so
um one there's a responsibility for
companies that are good at this to act
responsibly and two it's in our best
interest to provide the tools to allow
people to understand what's going on and
to protect themselves so another debate
around this is uh will it create or
displace workers and a good example or
or kind of coraly is uh in the banking
sector a lot of people don't remember
but when ATMs first came out uh they
were like oh bank tellers are never
going to have a job again we're going to
literally put all the bank tellers out
of business uh and I recently was
talking to a friend about this and I
looked it up there's more bank tellers
today than any time ever in history and
so ATMs actually increased access to the
financial system which then led to the
need for more bank tellers how do you
look at some of this AI specifically
around audio like there's voice actors
but there's also a number of other ways
that people use audio uh either in
commercial settings or for you know kind
of personal income and so do we end up
displacing some of those people or do we
actually create the need for more human
voice you know uh kind of components so
I I'll answer your question from from a
historical perspective and then I'll
answer about today um what is the
difference between humans and you know
normal animals for the most part right
some people say maybe it's opposable
thumbs but really one of the biggest
definitions is the ability to create
tools and so every time a human creates
tools uh Society leap rocks forward
right whether it be the steam engine or
the plow or whatever and so back in the
day people were like oh my gosh not the
plow you know you will you know take us
out of a job not the cotton gin not the
train instead of a horse not the
computer not the calculator not the
internet and so the idea the technology
will displace humans is fanciful because
at the end of the day we are humans and
so you know the human condition is
taking tools and using them to your
benefit now the big problem is who
controls and has access to these tools
because you will have a situation where
wealth acrs to people who have access to
these tools and learn how to use them uh
um and so you gave a great example which
is the bank tellers and so it's just a
tool that gives you more leverage right
I think it's aredes gave me a lever long
enough and I can move the world um and
so here's how to think about
it I was having a conversation with a
really exceptional voice actress uh not
long ago and she asked me exactly the
same question and uh she has a bunch of
contracts with government agencies um
with companies with the military where
you know YouTubers Etc and she's limited
by how many times a day she can speak
and if you speak for hours a day you
know this you know your voice gets horse
like what can you do about it and so I
was explaining to her listen here's I'll
give you a free access to the speechify
uh B2B Suite upload your voice take all
the clients that you currently have and
send them a Year's worth of work in the
next two weeks and then see whether they
tell you the quality is good enough or
not good enough and if it's good enough
great you just made like 300,000
additional dollars per year if it's not
good enough get really good at editing
your voice to make sure that it sounds
the way that it needs to for that piece
of content
and if it needs to be something that's
exceptionally high quality you need to
make the director's cut decision-making
about you know it should be sad it
should be happy it should be this it
should be that but this is just a tool
that allows you to multiply yourself in
the same way that photoshop and
Lightroom made it so much easier for
creators to have bigger impact um you
know it used to be that to make film you
need to literally cut physical film and
like paste it together and now we're
doing this over zoom and you'll be able
to push it out and millions of people
will benefit from it um and so the key
here is everybody needs to learn so I
have a friend who has a great quote
which is a little bit of slope makes up
for a lot of Y intercept it's not where
you start out it's your growth curve
over time and so if you are a person who
is determined to not learn and stay
exactly as you are yes AI will displace
you but not because the AI displaces you
AI will displace you because people who
have started out at a lower position
from you will pass you very quickly
because they learned how to use new
tools and so there is a pressure and a
ownness on every single s Le person out
there today in the same way that you had
to learn how to touch type how to use
the computer how to use Google how to
use chat GPT if you're not learning how
to use new tools as they come out you
will be displaced not by the tools but
by people who use the tools now you
mentioned that you have these
Partnerships with Mr Beast Snoop Dogg
Etc describe a little bit how you guys
think about those Partnerships and are
they making money off of it are they
having some other sort of benefit is it
just like hey get your eyeballs on Snoop
Dog's voice and that makes him more
valuable for you know other types of um
you uh production or or commercial
engagement how does it work so yeah
exactly right so we had to go and write
the first contract ever for a digital
licensing of someone's voice um for
Perpetual use and um you know it's a mix
and depending on the person so a lot for
us is like can the person bring in new
customers topify so if they have a large
following in the post you know they get
a certain um share from those so they
bring it to the platform for the most
part A lot of people come to us and ask
hey can you just post my voice they
consider it like the new version of
Instagram ification right like anybody
can get verified now but like not
everybody can get their voice as a
public voice on speechify um you can
upload your own but it's like a very
high status thing if you can get your
voice to be you know one of the default
voices um and once your voice is there
you build a crazy amount of affinity
with your audience so um what's funny is
like my voice happened to be one of the
first voices in speech ofi because you
know I was working on it but it's the
third most popular voice in speech ofy
um and sometimes I'll meet people and
they'll be like oh my God like I've
listened to your voice for like hundreds
of hours um and so you have this like
very strong Affinity with a person and
if you are Mr Beast or Snoop Dogg a lot
of your business is not just um being
well known but being known well and so
it's having that you know intense
relationship with your audience and when
your audience is going to sleep and
you're the one that's narrating to them
when they're doing your work like you're
having a conversation with them for
hundreds of hours on a regular basis um
and so it really really impacts uh the
level of affinity that people build um
with those Partners um and then the the
place where it gets really fun is
sometimes Snoop Doug will get you know
called to do a commercial and he doesn't
have time to do the commercial but he
can license speech ofice voice for the
commercial and still make money without
even need to step foot in the studio has
he been doing that uh this is something
that a bunch of people have been doing
um both through you know different um uh
agencies and through just the the web
portal for speechy and I don't know how
much you know about the individual um
deals but are they actually getting paid
the same price or if it is the AI voice
will they actually get paid less so it's
like more cost effective for the agency
and the product owner as well yeah yeah
I mean if you look at you know any aess
celebrity like their day rate is going
to be you know $800,000 for the day
whether they're on set or they're in the
studio you're paying for their time so
the second that you disin
disintermediate away their time you're
just paying for the value without paying
for the time and so by definition it's
going to be a lot cheaper yeah so
actually there may be a world where they
start to incentivize say hey actually we
don't want you want your voice and
therefore it's way cheaper to be able to
do that and the other thing that you'll
see is you know Marvel and Disney and
all these other Studios like they'll
shoot and then they'll need to re like
reinvite the actors into the studio in
order to you know add dubbing add
background audio um you know all that
jazz and like you're still paying the
day rate and so what you'll have is in
the contracts in the future it'll say
hey we are paying you for your likeness
and your image and your time on camera
but we're also paying for an exclusive
license for this movie to generate
additional versions of your voice
because it just allows the process to be
faster and this obviously has to happen
with permission it should not happen
without permission you're still the
person who owns your likeness who owns
your voice um you just need to license
it and in the same way that you license
someone to use your photo you can
license someone to use a likeness of
your voice so another thing this becomes
pretty interesting is let's say that I
was to put my voice on a platform
somebody was to come and license it uh I
know that it's going to go into x movie
let's say uh and then all of a sudden I
don't like the script and they made me
say something that I wouldn't have said
or I didn't want to say I did license it
to them but there's Nuance now how do
you see that stuff playing out and that
may be kind of an extreme example for
movies sure today's episode is brought
to you by trust and will I've gone
through a number of different changes in
my life over the last few years I got
married I had a kid and I had to start
thinking about how could I ensure that
my wife and my child would be okay if
anything ever happened to me that's
where trust wills and estate planning
come into play now most people what they
do is they get introduced to a friend an
uncle or someone in their local
community it tends to be someone who's
really expensive a lawyer an accountant
or somebody who does Estate Planning and
they just simply are using a one-size
fits-all template and just telling you
pay me thousands of dollars and I'll use
the same thing for you as the guy down
the street but that's not what trust and
will does they have a trusted online
estate planning product that starts as
low as
$159 which allows you to now protect
your legacy from the comfort of your own
home leverage their excellent customer
support available via phone email or
chat they have thousands of five-star
reviews and a rating of excellent on
trust pilot it takes most people 20 to
30 minutes to complete their estate plan
with trust and will and not only that
but if you go to trustand will.com pomp
you'll get 10% off plus you'll get free
shipping of all your estate planning
documents so go to trust and will.com
Pomp and make sure you get an estate
plan in place whether it's for you or
one of your loved ones having a trust
Andor a will can literally be the
difference between someone being taken
care of and someone not go check them
out today at trust and
will.com pomp um I it's exactly the same
way as if you sign yourself up to being
a reality TV show and they can cut it
however you want in reality TV shows
sometimes they'll shoot over your
shoulder you're saying one thing and
then you you see you know the back of my
head but they'll take a clip of me
saying something else from a completely
different thing and the person is like
do you want to kill me and I said of
course not but then they switch of me
saying yes right they have creative
license and you sign that away when you
participate in any movie in any TV show
in any whatever so it's not that
different it is true that you should
always only partner with people that you
actually believe are good people and if
you are partnering with people who you
think are Bad actors to begin with then
you know that's what's gonna happen
absolutely talk to me about the company
itself in terms of how big is it Revenue
wise number of employees what what data
or information can you share with us
yeah yeah so I started working on
speechy back in 2015 and the reason I
wased about it is I read a bunch of uh
academic papers about the narrow
applications of deep learning
specifically around speech enthesis and
my thesis
was I'm gonna be able we're gonna have
text to speech be more than 10x better
than it currently is like this is
absolutely insane and I ended up writing
this 30 page paper about my World Views
and the conclusion was that I'm the
person I am today because of my
experience overcoming dyslexia when I
was a kid and because I listen to two
audiobooks a week and I've done that for
like the last 17 years 100 books per
year and I was like this is the most
important piece of technology for me to
invest my time in and this is why I'm on
this Earth is to solve dyslexia to solve
ADHD um and uh I'm so lucky that
audiobooks existed when I was 9 10 11
years old because if I was born 15 years
earlier 20 years earlier I would not
have had the academic experience that I
had but not at all i' be a completely
different person um and yet most
textbooks did not have an audiobook and
so that's what we set out to do now
there's about a little more than 100
people who work at speechi we're like 75
Engineers 30 people on the AI team my
brother Tyler um is actually blind in
his left eye he's astigmatic in his
right eye and so he does all of his
coding on a giant projector but he
started coding when he was in third
grade uh building triangle ballsy
websites he taught himself uh assembly
in fifth grade to hack video games he
skipped three and a half years of math
in high school three years of computer
science then he did math as an undergrad
at Stanford he did his Masters in AI
there um and he joined the team and
leads the AI team for speech ofy um and
so we both have this very big passion of
making sure that reading is never aari
to learning for anyone no matter what
your background is and really above
everything else uh my goal in life is to
be the person that I needed most when I
was young when I was young the thing I
really needed was someone to do my
readings for me and so in the beginning
it was a bunch of people like me people
with dyslexia ADHD low vision autism
concussions anxiety second language
Learners now that's less than you know
30 20% most users of speech ofy are
doctors lawyers accountants people in
the military Executives people in
finance um who they like to listen when
they drive they like to listen when they
work out they like to listen when they
walk they like to listen with their cook
they find that they can listen two to
three times faster than they can read
they can comprehend better when they
listen and read at the same time it's
way less boring so the co contingent of
people who have used it the most um
happen to be people with ADHD what's
interesting is if you have ADHD or brain
is wild slightly differently turns out
you're way better at listening fast so
the percentage of people who I meet who
listen at 3x speed it's like 80% people
with ADHD because the speed of the
listening is equal to the speed at which
their mind is working and that helps
them but if you intake the text the 200
words per minute there's a dissidence
there you get bored you you act out in
class or you walk out to you know pet a
dog whatever it might be but the second
that it's equal to your brain which
already moves fast you're absolutely
locked
in um and so we have the the Chrome
extension is you know our most popular
product and then the iPhone app and then
we have the mobile web product and then
um the the B2B uh tools that we built
and so right now we're like 25 million
people the goal is to grow to 2.5
billion the thing is audio is a
fundamentally better user interface than
digital screens uh and it's funny
because almost every futuristic movie
that you see the predominant user
interface is audio right people talking
to their computer and the computer will
have wit and it'll be funny and it'll
have a nice voice whatever um and so our
goal is to build an auditory operating
system we started by solving a very um
single player mode problem which is how
do you read documents emails chat GPT
Google um physical books and have it
Kindle and have it in an exceptional
manner with super high quality voices
all the Integrations the ability change
speed to play pause to pick the word
that you want to listen to and for the
most part like we've cracked that we've
been the number one app in our app store
category for about four years above the
New York Times above the Wall Street
Journal and now a lot of the Investments
that we're doing is hey users listen to
so much content on speery there will
come a time where we can recommend to
you the most relevant material to you so
you have all these beautiful books
behind you let's assume that you
finished reading 80% of them and some of
them you stocked 25% of the way through
I can start recommending to you the most
relevant books for you to read next
based on what you actually completed
exactly like Tik Tok recommends videos
um and so except for entertainment it's
for business and knowledge purposes um
that to me is really really exciting it
gets even more exciting when you put it
in the context of a team so now we're
launching speechify teams um that knows
the entire knowledge base that all your
team has because it knows that you read
this macroeconomics paper about
inflation as it relates to solar panels
and I read this paper about gpus from
Nvidia and actually we should be the two
people called into the organization to
talk about this topic um and so that to
me is just like a very exciting future
when you think about audio everything
we've talked about is kind of the input
to the human right audio is coming in
I'm digesting the audio um there is the
audio interface though we see this with
Siri we see this with Alexa we see this
with you know a bunch of these different
products um is it just going to be kind
of a a a bodal or or kind of two-
directional I'm consuming audio but I'm
also using audio to kind of dictate my
life and and uh that's the dominant use
case kind of moving
forward so if you want to build an AI
company and there's like 10 fastest
growing generative AI companies
obviously open AI is number one speech
of is of to number like six or seven um
you got to think where value acrs right
and so there's two ways of thinking
about it the first one is does value ACR
to the person who has the best model um
or does it acrw in another place and
often that place actually ends up being
distribution because if you have the
largest amount of distribution you get
to train your models on more and more
data than everybody else um and so there
were many companies hundreds of
companies that were at the same level of
open AI during gpt1 gpt2 gpt3 the thing
that really changed everything is chat
GPT for speechify we started with being
user first and then we leaned really
hard into the deep fling part um and the
reason it took a little bit of time is
one I was a college student um and two
uh audio is a lot more uh heavy than
text and so obviously what you're going
to see is first you have this bottle
between open Ai and anthropic then
you'll have this bottle bottle to see
who is going to win the audio and
obviously speech of fine open out of two
leaders there and then you're going to
have this uh fight about like text to
video because that's the next thing that
is the most
heavy um and so it's not enough to just
have the foundational models and by the
way it's important to note that within
large language models in AI they're not
all the same some us are for textual
reasoning and some are for audio and
some are for video and some are for
other things so we're especially good at
the voice part um but it's not just
enough to have the foundational models
you need to have the end relationship
with a user and so the way that
speechify has decided to build build the
products that we create is they sit on
top of other software so if you think
about the technology stack and you think
about Microsoft they started with DOs
and then you so you start with an
operating system and then on top of that
you build applications call it the app
store or the you know Chrome browser and
then you build websites on top of that
and then on top of that you get to have
Chrome extensions like speedify or
mobile Safari extensions like speedify
or Gmail plugins like speedify and then
we end up being the conduit for
information intake you're the last piece
of technology you interface with before
the information gets into your brain and
then that's the input and now we're
starting to work on the output as well
so the output is important because it
helps you navigate it needs to be able
to deal with interruptions it needs to
be able to deal with sound in the
background and by the way what's very
interesting is if you're able to use
speech ofice technology and you're
recording a conversation like this let's
say I was in the middle of a stadium I
could transcribe my voice and then I
could text the speech my voice again
with the same intonation generate the
voice perfectly but drop all the
background audio drop all the additional
speakers drop if we're in a stadium the
bouncing of the basketball the sound the
Roaring or the crowd whatever it might
be and so you end up with these
fundamentally New Primitives for data on
the internet and that's really really
exciting and so what ends up happening
is the user interfaces change you're
going to have a situation in the next
like two three four years where your
airpods will be LTE compatible and you
can leave the house without your iPhone
and that's already kind of amazing
because you're not addicted to this
physical screen anymore and humans a lot
of the depressions that we're seeing
these days is people being sucky to the
social media platforms and you know
whatever it might be Tik Tok Instagram
but if you able to still get all the
value all the knowledge all the
entertainment all the learning without
being stuck with your face inside of
here but you can look up and you can
walk around you can be in nature and you
can roll your boat whatever it might be
while listening that's a far better
Human Experience and you can cook and
you can do it and the second that you
want to boom you take out your earphones
you interface with your child and so
that I think is a much more exciting
future than where we've been headed in
the last 10 years my last question for
you is a little bit more fun uh music
obviously people have heard you know the
Kan uh Renditions and many others um
those were were people who basically
were doing it more for entertainment
purposes and kind of to show what the
technology could do do you think music
artists will begin to use this
technology to basically say hey look
screw it I can just rather than go in
and record myself use my own voice and
figure out how to make you know chart
topping uh hits of course so we already
have a bunch of artists who work with us
um and it's really funny actually so
like one a really good example is a guy
who um there's people who they don't
want to record in the studio because the
studio sucks they want to record on
their phone um so they record on your
phone but what happens is you know we'll
capture the intonation everything you
have and then we'll spit it back out but
it'll be super high quality in a
lossless format because we regenerated
it from scratch so actually it starts to
not matter what microphone quality you
use and so you can record in the subway
as long as the vibe is right and you get
the intonation that you want boom you
can get it there um and the way that the
music industry works is you have a bunch
of people who will write hit songs and
then artists will try it on during a
studio session and they'll keep the one
that they really really like and so now
what you can have is every artist they
can just listen to a a stable of songs
sang with their voice and then they can
decide before they even actually go to
record whether they like it or not and
you're GNA have artists who already have
a really big name be able to feature on
any song you want as long as they give
permission uh and that's really
interesting you obviously have artists
like Grimes who are publicly allowing
anybody to use her voice um and just
like you know 50% split it you'll see
more things like this again it's not a
solution for creativity
but it is a solution for more efficient
execution Cliff where can we send people
to find you on the internet or learn
more about
speechify uh easiest place is follow me
on YouTube or Instagram Cliff Weisman C
FF Wei TZ M an I also write a lot on
medium if you want to find speechify uh
search on the App Store speechify speech
and then ify or go download the Chrome
extension for speechify use it to listen
to your emails it'll save you a lot of
time amazing we'll do it again in the
future great Anthony great to meet you